This,
this interest in mania as this interest
in these levees,
where did all this come from?
What's there?
Can you go back maybe to an earlier time
where this kind of an obsession or took
hold the view?
Well,
it's,
I wouldn't call it an obsession because
it would be a wrong description of
myself to be obsessive.
I'm not,
I'm just very calm and I'm trying to be
a thinking men and people always think I
this madman in this obsessed and he must
be insane.
I didn't take,
I didn't know,
but I know what's out there.
I know,
I know all the top locking us out there.
And I have to say I'm the only one
probably in southern England who is
clinically sane.
So one example.
All right.
Yeah,
no,
but uh,
how to,
how can I describe it?
It in a,
in a way possibly dated back to my
childhood,
which is spent in the,
in a very remote mountain village in
Bavaria.
You moved when you were three,
four days old now,
10 or 14 days old and bombs hit Munich
and my mother fled because of bomb
pettit right next to our place.
And then you went to this tiny town of
Zach's suck cornea,
which is not even a town.
It's a tiny village and devastate a
farmhouse outside,
outside of Saffron.
And that's where I grew up.
And of course I had no idea of the world
outside.
As you know,
I had never seen cinema until I was 11 I
didn't even know that cinema existed.
And in his children,
his children,
we had nothing.
I mean we were,
we were always very hungry.
That's must one side.
But it didn't really matter.
It mattered to the mothers.
It was very,
very hard for the mother to not be able
to feed the children.
But we had no toys and we had no games
and we had to invent to games.
And you found you found toys?
Yeah,
well found toys.
I wouldn't call it toys with toys.
We found weapons.
We found live and ammunition mission and
pursue costs and things like this.
And you've,
you've spoken about that moment in time
as a,
as a happy moment in [inaudible] was
very happy,
very wonderful childhood with my
brothers and other refugee children and
farm children around.
And we were getting a 14,
actually 13 and one girl,
uh,
she,
she was always with us and she was the
rowdiest the most true,
mostly independent and in courageous of,
of us all.
And,
um,
yeah.
And of course,
I dreamt of,
um,
uh,
of shooting a crow because I had seen
the route workers who had shot a crow.
Nobody had anything to eat,
and they pluck the feathers and they
cooked it.
And there was,
there was on,
on,
uh,
on the top of the soup there was,
as we called it,
ice of fat floating,
which was sensational.
And we were hungry and I wanted to shoot
a crow,
but I'd never managed to the machine.
Submachine gun was too,
too unruly.
But,
uh.